welcome to the David packman show I am
fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in once again today for David
Pac-Man we've got a wonderful show
coming up for you today Jim Jordan is
being sued by Alvin Bragg Melania Trump
is furious at the media for talking
about all of her marriage problems
Dianne Feinstein is facing more and more
calls to resign after it was revealed
that she has missed more than 60 votes
this year and of course
all the legal problems with Donald Trump
all of that and more is coming up on
today's program so let's jump right into
it Alvin Bragg Manhattan district
attorney has announced that he is suing
Republican representative Jim Jordan and
pretty much the house Judiciary
Committee trying to stop a subpoena that
Jordan issued last week
for Mark pomerance
now I had already thought that the idea
to subpoena Mark pomerance by Jim Jordan
was very dumb
if you're not familiar with Mark
pomerance he is one of the two former
assistant prosecutors at the Manhattan
DA's office along with Carrie Dunn they
worked under Cyrus Vance on the Trump
investigation and pomerance and Dunn
resigned last year and pomeranz has
revealed since then in both his
resignation letter and his new book that
he resigned because when Alvin Bragg
took over from cyvance he pretty much
killed the investigation into Donald
Trump
pomerance has gone as far as to say
that he advance
actually had the indictments drafted
against Donald Trump he said they were
less than 10 days away from charging
Donald Trump with financial crimes
and then Brad came in put that
investigation on ice and the rest is
history right
well Jim Jordan for some reason thought
it would be a smart idea
to bring pomerance into the house
Judiciary Committee to testify because
he thought pomeranz's testimony would
somehow prove that Alvin Bragg had
actually weaponized
the Manhattan DA's office to go after
Trump
and he weaponized it to go after Trump
by not going after Trump according to
the guy Jim Jordan
wants to talk to in the house so
um if it's a little confusing don't
worry it's very confusing Jim Jordan's
strategy here makes no sense at all
pomerance is not going to waltz into the
house Judiciary Committee and say oh
yeah Alvin Bragg absolutely weaponized
this no he's gonna say based on what
he's already said that Alvin Bragg
should have gone harder after Donald
Trump and then he's going to start
laying out all the evidence they had
against Donald Trump with the financial
crimes
so if pomerance goes to that Judiciary
Committee hearing it's going to make Jim
Jordan look even dumber than he already
has this year
like that's a good thing I want that to
happen
but I can understand why Alvin Bragg
doesn't and that of course is why Alvin
Bragg is suing to stop this subpoena
from happening and honestly legally
speaking he has very strong grounds
under which to challenge this subpoena
he can easily say that obviously because
these are ongoing investigations they
have not been closed we under New York
state law are forbidden from turning
over evidence from turning over
documents related to ongoing
investigations to third parties and at
this point because Congress does not
directly oversee the Manhattan DA's
office they would be considered a third
party it'd be no different than handing
over the information that they've
gathered to Fox News
that's kind of how Congress is for the
Manhattan DA's office you're just an
independent third party sure you've got
some power
but you have no power here
so he has very strong legal grounds
under which to challenge this subpoena
but I kind of wish he wouldn't
I really really really want Mark
pomerance to waltz into that uh chamber
and spill the beans on all of the
horrible evidence that they uncovered in
their Trump investigation that is what I
want to see and I think a lot of people
probably want to see that as well if
we're gonna air some dirty laundry let's
air it out let's put it all out there on
the line for the world to see because
that's what Jim Jordan wants to do and I
think in this particular instance we
need to honor Jim Jordan's request
we need to give him exactly what he
wants
because I believe it was Oscar Wilde who
said you know there's two great
tragedies in life one is not getting
what you want
the other is getting exactly what you
want
so let's give Jim Jordan exactly what he
wants let's give him Mark pomerance's
testimony about the investigations into
Donald Trump let's let the entire
country hear what Mark pomerance has to
say about all of that evidence about the
indictments that they had drafted
and about why those indictments didn't
get filed let's hear it from him
but that's not what Jim Jordan wants to
hear it's what he would hear but it's
not what he wants to hear he wants to
hear pomerance go in there and whine and
cry and say oh Alvin Bragg made us look
at this stuff and we didn't want to we
knew it was phony baloney
yeah that ain't gonna happen
but
flip side of the coin as I said I
understand why Bragg doesn't want this
to happen
if pomerants were to go into a Judiciary
Committee hearing and start saying that
Bragg was a weak prosecutor we had all
this strong evidence he chose not to do
it it's going to make Bragg look bad and
then you're going to have people on the
left as well as all of the freaks on the
right hating on Alvin Bragg and that's
not what we need right now
I am still annoyed I'm still angry that
Alvin Bragg did not go after Donald
Trump for the big Financial crimes that
pomerance and Don and Vance were all
investigating and ready to indict him
for I think that was a mistake I think
that was a giant misstep based on the
statements that pomerance has already
made publicly it seems very clear that
they had Donald Trump red-handed in a
lot of these instances now that would
have been up for a jury to decide
but now a jury is not even going to get
the opportunity to decide that
and that's not fair
if the indictments were ready as
pomerantz says they were they should
have been filed
Bragg didn't want to go that route
Bragg went the route he did he got his
indictments you know 34 counts against
Donald Trump trial coming up probably in
about a year so it all worked itself out
but Bragg doesn't want palmerance to
talk and again I understand why and I
understand there's laws in New York that
would likely prevent pomerance from
saying the things that I want to hear
him say
but
Bragg has the law on his side Jim Jordan
only has politicization the
weaponization of the weaponization
committee
and maybe he wins maybe he doesn't we'll
see what happens as this lawsuit that
braggis filed plays itself out in the
court system
and speaking by the way of Jim Jordan
weaponizing the weaponization committee
it was revealed this week that Jim
Jordan
has sent letters to multiple different
colleges and universities across the
country
demanding all of the information about
their efforts to research
disinformation in American politics
according to the letter
that Jim Jordan sent to these colleges
he said quote certain third parties
including organizations like yours may
have played a role in this censorship
regime by advising on so-called
misinformation
so he's going after colleges now he
already failed and going after Twitter I
mean we all remember Matt Tybee coming
in there and testifying and uh
didn't didn't go so well and if you've
been paying attention to the most recent
drama between taibi and musk uh that
relationship has had a horrible falling
out but
Jim Jordan so far has come up with
nothing with this weaponization
committee
so he is grasping at straws now remember
when he brought in those FBI so-called
whistleblowers that all turned out to be
extremist Trump supporters who actually
hated the FBI so they weren't actually
whistleblowers they were just mad at the
agency because they didn't like it and
then they delivered no explosive
Bombshells in their testimony and it was
revealed of course that a couple of them
had actually gotten some money from Kosh
Patel one of Donald Trump's close allies
uh from his group yeah it was a whole
big mess and it made Jim Jordan look
very stupid just like the Twitter files
hearing made him look very stupid
so now he's going after colleges he's
saying how dare you how dare you
research misinformation
and then how dare you I suspect
give that information to social media
companies or the Biden Administration
now the thing is based on the letter Jim
Jordan doesn't even know that that
happened
Jim Jordan is just making these wild
accusations against colleges saying I
think you probably may have could have
at some point thought about possibly
thinking about doing these things
That's the basis for this investigation
folks
the problem is even though these
colleges have nothing to hide
they also don't want to have to spend
time hiring lawyers you know sending
their people down to Washington DC to go
and testify wasting man hours going
through all of their research compiling
it in a way that Congress can actually
read
that takes time and money
something that a lot of colleges don't
necessarily have a lot of on hand
especially for something like this
so according to some of the researchers
at these colleges
they're already worried that this is
going to have a chilling effect on their
efforts to combat misinformation in the
United States
ahead of the 2024 election
multiple sources who spoke to propublica
about this story say that they are
worried that colleges rather than have
to live under Congressional scrutiny
will simply scrap the programs or scale
them back to the point where they become
completely ineffective
and that's the goal
that's what Jim Jordan wants that's what
Republicans want
they don't want colleges and
universities you know smart people
looking at the amount of misinformation
flowing all day every day on social
media
because what is that going to point
fingers back to
it's not going to point fingers back to
this show it's not going to point
fingers back to my show
it's not going to point fingers at at
Sam cedar or any of the other folks who
do this Jesse dalamore no it's not going
to come after us
it's going to come after your your
Charlie Kirks and your Candice Owens and
your Fox News and your daily wires daily
callers daily morons whatever it is
those are the ones that are going to get
flagged for misinformation
because those are the ones that are
filled with misinformation with
disinformation with lies of omission
if you've spent any time
watching conservative media reading
conservative Outlets
you quickly begin to realize as a
rational person
um there are some things missing here
there's some context missing there's a
quote that you've taken and distorted
that is commonplace in a lot of
conservative media
sometimes they just outright make things
up and they never get held accountable
right we're not seeing slander libel and
defamation lawsuits filed left and right
against these organizations
we should but we don't
so the only weapon we have are these
institutions that are actively
investigating misinformation and calling
it out and Reporting on it
and Jim Jordan knows that and he also
knows we're heading into a contentious
2024 election cycle he doesn't want
people hyper focused on the lies coming
from the right so he's trying to have
this chilling effect on This research
through his requests to these colleges
that is the point of it that is the goal
that is what he wants to do
and some folks at the colleges are
already admitting it's probably going to
work
look I am fair and cousins you can
follow me on YouTube at youtube.com the
ring of fire also youtube.com fair and
balanced I am on Twitter Facebook
Instagram and Tick Tock at
fahrenbalanced this is the David packman
show and we'll be right back with more
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in once again today for David
Pacman I hope David is enjoying his time
away
meanwhile we've got more news to talk
about specifically I want to hit on
something that I touched upon in
yesterday's show yesterday I mentioned
that throughout my entire lifetime
Republicans have not had an actual
economic plan that goes beyond let's cut
taxes for the rich and I wanted to
expand upon that idea because I think
it's something worth discussing
especially since we're going to be
heading into election season here long
uh not long out in fact we are
technically already in 2024 election
season so it's important to talk to
people about what the Republican party
of today
and of the last 40 years actually stands
for
and the answer is nothing
the Republican Party stands for nothing
I know they have a a party platform I
know they say they like small government
but then they they pass all these laws
letting the government intrude I mean
quite literally to inspect your genitals
that that doesn't seem like small
government at all yet you're passing
laws Republican party at the state level
that will actually allow the government
to inspect your genitals
that that's not very small governmenty
but here's the big point
throughout my entire life and I turned
40 years old two months ago
so I've been on this Earth for 40 years
I was born during the Reagan
Administration
subsequently lived through every other
Republican Administration I have lived
in a red state that has been solidly
controlled by a republican governor and
a Republican state legislature for 25
straight years here in Florida
so I know a thing or two about having to
live under solid Republican Rule and I
can tell you from my experience and from
working in Progressive media for 19
years
Republicans don't know how to govern
it's that simple that is the line
Republicans have no idea what they're
doing what have we seen from them in the
last 40 years and I use that time frame
because that's when the Republican Party
really kicked into this shift when
Reagan came into office but it also
happens to be the time frame I've been
alive so I I like to focus on that
for 40 years the Republican party's
entire Economic Policy whether it's at
the federal level or the state level has
been one idea and one idea alone
let's cut taxes for the wealthy
that's it
that is all that party knows how to do
even with their Republican majority in
the house right now they've already
talked about extending the Trump tax
cuts
you know we're worried about the debt
ceiling we're worried about inflation
you know the supply chain shortages the
gas prices they wouldn't shut up about
last year but went completely silent
when gas prices fell again none of that
actually matters to them now that
they're in power the only thing they've
wanted to do other than carry out
investigations into stupid things
is cut taxes
make sure that tax cuts stay there
part of the debt ceiling negotiations
may include repealing or changing of the
inheritance tax again
because that is the only thing
Republicans know how to do think back
just a few years ago right when
Republicans were trying to draft their
health care bill and it turned into a
tax cut bill like that's all it had by
the time it was finished it was just a
bunch of tax cuts
everything they touched turns into just
tax cuts because that's all they know
how to do and it's not tax cuts for you
or me it's tax cuts for people like them
because that is their economic policy
if they had to actually sit and govern
and deal with the problems that they
love to whine about during campaigns if
they had to try to do something about
inflation if they had to try to
understand monetary policy and how the
debt actually works in this country
they wouldn't know what to do
and I say that because we're watching
them right now try to deal with these
things
and they don't know what to do
but it's not just the issue of Economics
that Republicans have failed this
country on for the last 40 years I want
everybody to to think for a moment when
was the last time that a republican
majority
passed a piece of legislation at the
federal level
that benefited the lives of average
working-class Americans
can you think of a single specific
instance
where they did something like that
because again almost 20 years of working
in Progressive media literally
researching and doing things like this
every day I can tell you I can't think
of a single one
because they don't have one
we have seen them bust up unions which
has hurt the middle class
we have seen them ignore environmental
pollution and destruction which is
harming low-income and middle-income
American people they live in areas that
are you know tend to be statistically
far more polluted than where the one
percent lives
they have done nothing to make your life
better
they've done plenty to make it worse you
know at the state level passing the
right to work laws which is basically
right to work for Less
passing laws that allow massive
corporations to come up Buy in entire
neighborhoods or buy up entire
neighborhoods excuse me and price you
out of the housing market
that's happening all over the country
right now because Republicans are
letting it happen
they don't know how to do anything about
any actual real problems
so what do we do what are we hearing
this week what is the biggest issue for
the Republican party this week
Bud Light
I know you've seen it
I've done my best to try to not talk
about it but you know sometimes you kind
of have to we've got real actual
problems in the country we've got a debt
ceiling crisis we've only got like two
months left to figure it out before we
have to start shutting down agencies and
programs
and you've got Marco Rubio going on Fox
News saying this week that our Global
standing
has decreased our allies are now
abandoning us because of Bud Light
that's what Marco Rubio said
I'm paraphrasing a bit there but he said
all this wokeness
because you've gotten men you know
Hawking Nike sports bras and and a
transgender influencer
promoting Bud Light our allies are now
like Whoa We may have to go it alone
that's what Marco Rubio said
they want to distract you from the real
issues because they don't even
understand the real issues like let's
forget for a moment everything I said
that they don't know how to govern
that's true that's a given but I'm at
the point now where I genuinely think
they don't even understand how to do it
it's bad enough that they won't govern
it's even worse to think that they
literally don't know how to do it which
is why they push the culture War BS on
us it's why we end up talking about Bud
Light for a week it's why they went
after Eminem's it's why they went after
Oreos and Keurigs and Nikes and Yeti
coolers and Dr Seuss and Mr Potato Head
I mean good God how many things have the
Republicans tried to cancel in recent
years because they allegedly went woke
we have seen interviews with Republican
you know Trump supporters out there even
some Republican politicians are on video
ask what CRT is and none of them can
tell you but they know they want to ban
it
they don't even know what it is and they
want to ban it not because it's a threat
but because it gets their low
information base riled up
this is the same base that is getting
destroyed by these Republican economic
policies by these Republican
environmental policies by all of these
know-nothing Republicans
and they just keep doing it because
they're like yeah but we like the
culture War stuff I don't I don't want
to walk into a bathroom and see a guy
wearing a dress taking a whiz as if
that's an issue that affects anybody on
the planet
but that's what they tell us to worry
about that's what they want us to focus
on
because that is the only thing they know
how to do
and according to Washington Post
reporter Jennifer Rubin
that's going to come back to bite
Republicans in the 2024 election
Jennifer Rubin with the Washington Post
had a great new article this week the
title is right-wing judges May
the GOP
and she spends about a page and a half
talking of course about last week's
ruling with regard to the Texas judge
who banned the abortion pill
used a bunch of activist language in the
ruling you know completely violated the
uh I think it's a six-year statute of
limitations to even challenge the FDA on
a drug being on the market because
mephess perone uh uh uh forgot how to
say it I'm so sorry
um
Stone has been on the market for 20
years so the judge way missed the
statute of limitations but still decided
nope I'm going to ban it anyway
and the Public's pissed and that's what
Jennifer Rubin is talking about so let
me read this from Reuben's article again
I think it's very well written and I
think it's very on point here it is
it is one thing to Gin up the base on
the uninvented threats from critical
race Theory or the great replacement
Theory but when the Maga movement's
judges begin to inflict radically
unpopular edicts on those outside the
right-wing audience that risk sparking a
counter response a determined
broad-based movement insistent that the
United States not turn the clock back on
Decades of social progress Republican
setbacks such as the disappointing 2022
midterms a progressive Democrat last
week winning a crucial Wisconsin Supreme
Court seat and Rising support for
abortion rights over the past year
suggests that conservatives may have won
the battle to stack the courts with
ideologues but might be losing the war
for public opinion and ultimately
electoral control the more the Supreme
Court diverges from overwhelming public
sentiment on issues such as abortion
guns and voting rights the more strength
and more allies the Progressive Movement
May gain
I kind of like the sound of that now
it's obviously not worth losing our
rights in the meantime because God only
knows if we're ever going to get him
back but Reuben's overall Theory
is that it's one thing for these
horrible Republican politicians like
what we have down here in Florida you
know to push the CRT bans to push the
transgender bans to go after woke Disney
and you know the same things happening
in Texas with the bands in Oklahoma and
all the red States it's one thing to do
it at the state level because you're
doing it to an audience that typically
likes these things because as I
previously said they don't understand
them
but when the judges come in
those decisions aren't local
those decisions are national
meaning they don't just affect the red
States they're affecting the blue States
but more importantly they're affecting
those swing States
kind of like the overturning of Roe Did
Last Summer that played a massive role
in what happened in the 2022 midterm
elections
we even saw red States like a a Kansas
veto on their ballot in 2022
a ban on abortion
so even in red States these things
aren't that popular
and if these judges continue down this
path as Reuben says you're handing 2024
to the Democrat well to the progressive
she says it's even better
hand it to us we'll take it
we'll fix the problems we have ideas
we have better ideas than Republicans
have because r d ideas don't involve tax
cut tax cut tax cut
but in the meantime people suffer and
that's not okay
that's not okay at all
these activist judges are doing the job
that Republicans put them there to do
and the voters need to remember that
when they head to the polls next year
yes the judges might be the ones doing
it
but you have to punish at the ballot
the ones who put those judges there in
the first place otherwise you're going
to end up with more Republican activist
judges giving even worse rulings than
what we've already seen
I am Faron cousins sitting in for David
packman don't forget you can find me at
youtube.com the ring of fire youtube.com
fair and balanced and all across social
media at farrenbalanced we'll be right
back with more on the David packman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
welcome back to the David packman show I
am Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today as he enjoys
a nice little break from all of the
insanity happening in the world of
politics so let's Jump Right In to all
of that Insanity late last week a judge
judge Arthur Inger on the one overseeing
Donald Trump's upcoming trial for the
250 million dollar lawsuit filed against
him and his kids by New York attorney
general Leticia James Ingram ruled last
week
that Donald Trump's new accounting firm
cannot continue to Shield his financial
records and they must turn them over to
Leticia James
now you may be thinking to yourself but
farron the judge had already ruled that
Donald Trump's accounting firm had to
give all of this information to Leticia
James right mazars Donald Trump's
accounting firm was ordered to turn all
of the financial documents over they're
vital to the case
that is true so Donald Trump did what
most major corporations did and he
employed a tactic known as the Texas
two-step typically we see it in
corporations facing billions of dollars
in lawsuits what they do is they create
a new subsidiary spin off all of the
liability but none of the money into
that subsidiary then file for bankruptcy
saying hey you can't sue us because we
got no money
now Trump's little scheme here his
version of the Texas two-step was
slightly different what he did was as
soon as the judge said hey mazars you
got to turn over this financial
information Trump said okay mazar's I'm
taking it away from you and I am putting
it down in Texas where they have very
strict privacy laws with a firm called
Whitley Penn
and so for the last few months Whitley
Penn who now holds Donald Trump's
Financial records has been telling
Leticia James that hey sorry
under Texas law right this guy's our
clients you know we love him dearly
we've known him for days we can't give
you his documents because Texas law
prohibits that
so ingeron of course was forced to step
in and say no
no you can't do that I I'd already
ordered all of these documents
regardless of who held them
to turn them over and that was when the
documents were in fact by the way in my
jurisdiction here in New York they were
moved after the ruling you have no claim
to continue to hide them
so Donald Trump's financial documents
should
should is the key word be handed over to
Leticia James so that she can continue
on with her 250 million dollar lawsuit
against Trump and his kids
now
this is probably going to be appealed
that's what Trump does he he does the
delay tactic he tries to exhaust all of
his appeals so that he can make sure
he's fought as hard as he can to hide
these documents but again
when you look at the facts of the
situation while the documents were in
custody in New York they were ordered to
be delivered
they were moved after that order came
down Whitley Penn should have no legal
claim to continue to keep them hidden
because the order came while the
documents were in the jurisdiction of
the judge like it's pretty black and
white it's pretty simple I don't think
this will or could be overturned on
appeal
but we've seen some wacky things come
out of the court systems not necessarily
with regard to Donald Trump he he tends
to lose a lot throughout most of his
life
so I have every every faith that this
ruling is going to stand but it is quite
telling isn't it
Trump was ordered to turn over these
documents rather than turn them over he
decided to hide them
now I'm not on the jury I haven't seen
the documents all I can do is speculate
at this point
but if I'm looking at this case as a
prospective juror
because they will know that the
document's removed all right this public
knowledge
I'm going to be asking myself why after
he was ordered to turn them over did he
go and hide them in Texas that that
doesn't sound like something that
somebody who is totally innocent would
do does it
again I'm not on the jury I'm not in New
York so I won't be on the jury but those
are questions
that the prosecution may ask during the
trial and those are questions that
Donald Trump's ragtag team of
second-rate attorneys are going to have
to have some pretty dang good answers
for otherwise it's only going to make
Donald Trump look guilty as hell in
front of that jury
but here's one person who doesn't
necessarily care if Donald Trump is
innocent guilty or what the heck happens
to him and that person happens to be his
spouse former first lady Melania Trump
after several weeks of trying to just
ignore all of the legal problems that
her husband is facing Melania Trump
finally came out this week and released
a statement attacking the media for all
of their reporting on her allegedly not
giving one single care about what is
happening to her husband
so let me read you this statement
because
I don't think this statement really says
what Melania had wanted it to say
here it is
news organizations have made assumptions
about the former first lady stance on
subjects that are personal professional
and political over the past few weeks in
these articles unnamed sources are cited
to bolster the author's claims
we ask readers to exercise caution and
good judgment when determining whether
or not stories concerning the former
first lady are accurate particularly
when they fail to cite Mrs Trump as a
source of information
so
you're not actually saying that they're
not accurate you're just saying hey
folks you may want to think for a minute
and and then decide if it's accurate
but you you're you're not denying the
stories by telling people make up your
own mind like that's that's what they
were already doing you don't have to
tell people to make up their own minds
because they've already made up their
own minds
and these reports citing Anonymous
sources sure I know how much that drives
you all crazy down there in Republican
land but they're talking to sources
close to you they're talking to people
who know you people who work for you
people who have been around you for
years
and they don't want to be named because
they probably don't want to lose their
jobs kind of seems like a pretty easy
Gig if you ask me probably pays pretty
well and yeah you don't want to lose it
but you also want the public to know
what's really happening so what we know
from Melania Trump based on recent
reporting I mean we've had reports you
know Rolling Stone Vanity Fair uh you
know pretty much all major Outlets The
Daily Beast Melania Trump as we all know
did not attend her husband's victory
speech after his indictment and
arraignment last Tuesday so she didn't
show up for that
previous reports before that even
happened said Melania Trump wants
nothing to do with her husband's legal
problems
she's going about living her life she
lives in a separate Wing at Mar-A-Lago
they do not share living quarters so
they're not even sleeping in the same
bed so that's usually a pretty big
indication that there's some marital
problems there and these reports say
that Melania spends most of her days
happy with with Baron and her parents
who also live down there and they're
just going about their lives as if none
of this is even happening
good for her right I'm not going to
fault you for that
your your marriage appears based on what
we see to be falling apart
you know based on all of the you know
Visual Evidence you don't even seem to
like the guy
I honest to God can't figure out why
you're even still with him you you look
miserable all the time when you're
around him and then when there's photos
or videos of you with not Donald Trump
you seem to look happy
I mean you know it doesn't take a a
marriage counselor to understand that
you are happier when you're not with
this guy so maybe it's time to cut bait
and just say hey thanks but uh I'm out
either way it's your life you do
whatever you want but
your your little message here your your
denial of the stories which isn't
actually a denial that doesn't help your
case
it just makes it sound like hey some of
these may be true some of them may not
be who knows I don't know do you
not exactly the Stellar statement that
you thought you were making so I don't
know maybe go back to the drawing board
maybe come up with a better statement
maybe deny the stories or hell maybe
confirm them put it all to rest the
focus is on your husband anyway nobody
wants to be talking about Melania she's
not doing anything like I said she's
living her life and seemingly happy
but don't go out there and and poke the
media and accuse them of things when
you're not even denying the things that
they're reporting
that's not exactly honest either
and while we're on the subject of the
trumps
Donald Trump did an interview this week
with Tucker Carlson the man who
in text messages revealed during the
Dominion lawsuit said he wished Trump
would go away he was looking forward to
never having to talk about him again
hates him with a passion
and then sat down like a little sad
puppy to interview Donald Trump and give
him a shoulder to cry on
but it wasn't Trump that was crying it
wasn't Tucker either because according
to Donald Trump's interview
it was actually the courthouse workers
in New York that were sobbing
uncontrollably when poor old Donald
Trump was brought in for the arraignment
here is what Donald Trump said to Tucker
they were incredible when I went to the
courthouse which is also a prison in a
sense
I'm sorry before I could even finish
that statement like what it's also kind
of like a print no it's actually not
like that's not what a courthouse is a
courthouse is a courthouse it's which
where you have trials it's where you
have arraignments it's where you
sometimes go to pay parking tickets it's
not the prison I'm sure they probably
have a holding cell there for people
that are held in contempt if there's not
a local County Jail nearby but a
courthouse is not in and of itself also
a prison so that's just a weird
statement and it's not even the dumbest
thing he said so I'll continue
they signed me in and I'll tell you
people were crying they were actually
crying he said
it's just sobbing just tears flowing
like a river throughout that Manhattan
Courthouse they had to put out wet floor
signs because the tears I guess were
just overwhelming
nobody was crying
if there was any crying taking place in
that courtroom that day it was most
likely tears of joy tears of joy that
Justice had finally caught up with
Donald Trump tears of joy that this man
was no longer to get away with
everything that he has been accused of
for years and years and years and years
tears of joy that maybe maybe
this guy might finally get his
comeuppance
but even then I don't even think they
were crying tears of joy they were just
people doing their jobs like it's just
our job but I will say if Donald Trump
thinks these workers in Manhattan love
him
there is video where Donald Trump was
you know they were kind of holding the
doors for people and then when it was
Trump's turn to walk through it they
just let it go and it almost hit him in
the face
so I I don't exactly think those workers
were in love with you not to mention
we're talking about a courthouse in
Manhattan
Donald Trump you are universally
disliked in Manhattan if this had been a
courtroom in Texas yeah you probably
would have had some some Die Hard Trump
supporters and they're crying for you
same thing if it was in Texas or Florida
or Alabama yeah I'd believe that story
then
but she has a point Donald like when
you're gonna lie to people and of course
Tucker Carlson didn't push back at all
because he's a coward but if you're
gonna lie to people you gotta make the
LIE believable Donald I mean come on
you've done this enough you know how to
play the game
nobody's gonna believe that these
Courthouse workers that other people
have seen were crying that day
there is nobody With Tears in their eyes
on video or in any of the pictures there
is no one coming out to corroborate your
story Tucker Carlson if he had a shred
of dignity would have pushed back on
this but of course he doesn't so he
didn't
but nobody in that Courthouse was sad
Donald except for you
and I say that because you've talked a
big game attacking that judge
before and after your arraignment but
you were silent during the arraignment
you said a total of about 10 words most
of them just one word at a time yes no
thank you not guilty
so when you actually had the opportunity
to stand up and tell that judge what you
thought you didn't do it because you're
also a coward so instead you then go
running to your little buddy Tucker
Carlson who again claims to hate you you
tell him a lie he doesn't push back
and nobody believed your story
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David packman show I am
Faron cousins sitting in for David
Pacman today if you want more from me
you can find me on YouTube at
youtube.com the ring of fire I also have
my other channel youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and I'm on Twitter
Facebook Instagram and Tick Tock at
farrenbalanced now I want to end in this
last segment with a couple of
interesting stories from throughout the
week that I felt needed a little bit
more exposure now to begin the show
today I talked about the fact that Alvin
Bragg has sued Jim Jordan to stop the
subpoena that he issued against mark
pomerantz now what I didn't mention
about that lawsuit was that contained
within the lawsuit
Bragg the Manhattan DA's office
outlined the threats the racist threats
that Bragg has received since the
indictments were announced
according to the report the DA's office
received more than one thousand calls
and emails from Trump supporters since
March 18th the day when Trump
inaccurately predicted his own arrest
many of those messages have been quote
overtly racist and anti-Semitic
someone read one of them here I'm going
to you know censor uh some of this stuff
because it's not appropriate hey George
Soros a whole puppet if you want
president Trump come and get me remember
we are everywhere
and we have guns
another one referred to Alvin Bragg the
first black man ever elected as top
prosecutor in New York called him black
trash
one of them called him AIDS infested
and here's the thing
I have talked repeatedly on my channels
about the fact that it's only a matter
of time before these threats turn into
material action
but it turns out as Bragg revealed
that's already happened let me read this
from Vice
Bragg received an envelope containing
white powder and a specific death threat
against him the letter was immediately
contained to prevent exposure and was
later determined to contain no dangerous
substance according to a letter Bragg
later circulated to his staff
so you had an angry Trump supporter send
a letter saying you know basically I
want you dead
and the letter contained a white powder
the white powder of course was obviously
meant to scare them because luckily this
Trump supporter couldn't get their hands
on anything actually dangerous
that doesn't change the nature of the
threat
they believed at the time it was real
they they almost have to believe that
it's real every time this comes in
and this is what happens this is what I
believe personally Trump wants to happen
that's why he's been out there attacking
Bragg he has called him an animal he has
called him a pervert a lunatic a maniac
those are all words that Trump has used
just in the last week to describe out to
describe Alvin Bragg to describe judge
Merchant
Donald Trump is going after judge
Merchant's family
are these attacks from Trump on these
individuals have to stop and the only
way you can stop that is for judge
Merchant to put a gag order in place
not that I think that would stop Trump
but if you violate the gag order the
judge in the you know issuing has to say
a single violation is a night in jail
like every time you violate this every
time you send out a tweet that's an
attack on one of these people you're
going to jail for a night
so if you send out a post on Truth
social with three different attacks
that's three nights in jail
that's what the judge could do that's
what the judge should do to protect
these people to protect Alvin Bragg to
protect himself and his family
but the judge had said in the order well
not necessarily in the order but in the
court discussions last week during the
arraignment the judge said look a gag
order is is a far-off thing I don't want
to do it
he urged Trump's lawyers to you know
tone it down to Reign them in and
clearly they failed to do that because I
don't think they want to do it and even
if they wanted to they're dealing with a
client that's not going to listen to
them
so the only possible option here is the
judge to put that gag order in place
people's lives could be at stake
I mean Trump posted the picture of him
with the baseball bat and then Alan
Bragg on the other side of it looking
like he was going to hit him
that's not okay that is violent imagery
that his base sees and they think oh
okay this is what he wants me to do that
is how those people operate
Trump doesn't have to do the damage
Trump doesn't have to be the one out
there getting violent
because he knows that if he just says a
couple of buzzwords to his base shows
them a couple of pictures
they'll take it from there
and I firmly believe personally
that that's got to be what Trump wants
moving on we've talked a lot about
Republicans it's now time to talk about
some problems that the Democrats have
and it's a problem unfortunately named
Democratic senator Dianne Feinstein
this week of course it was revealed that
Feinstein has missed 60 votes her
absence from the uh senate committee is
actually preventing Biden's judicial
nominees from being confirmed they can't
move out of committee because they have
to have her vote because she's been out
since uh early March with shingles she
is now out of the hospital of course she
only spent a few days there she's been
recuperating in her home in California
she's 89 years old
she is not running for reelection her
term ends at the end of the year 2024.
and it's time for her to resign
that is my personal opinion I think it's
time for Dianne Feinstein to resign
but I'm not saying she has to resign
because of her health issue I'm not
saying she has to resign because of her
age
my plan my idea is I have a plan I have
no control over any of this my idea
is she needs to resign for the good of
the democratic party not for the Biden
judges thing
but for the House of Representatives
we got three Democrats
that are going to be running
in that Senate primary next year and
because they're running in the Senate
primary they cannot run for their house
seats
so three of those Democrats running at
least two of them obviously will lose
their seats and will no longer be
elected officials here in the United
States
and what terrifies me
are the people we could lose
we could lose Katie Porter and Barbara
Lee from the House of Representatives
that thought terrifies me I love them
both they are vital voices in that House
of Representatives we need them there
the third person running of course is
Adam Schiff
and I hate to say it but I think Schiff
is probably the shoe-in for this job
I don't want him to be the one to get it
I'd love to have Katie Porter in the
Senate I'd love to have Barbara Lee in
the Senate but I don't want it to come
at the expense of the other one having a
job as an elected official because
they're both good people
so how do we overcome that
Dianne Feinstein resigns
what happens when she resigns well
California is one of 37 states that says
if a senator resigns or you know is no
longer in office during the rest of
their term
the governor gets to appoint their
replacement until the next election
Gavin Newsom
would be able to appoint the replacement
that replacement
is the one who would most likely go on
to obviously be the nominee for 2024
which could get rid of the need for the
primary
which means we wouldn't lose those
Democrats from the house now I know
that's a weird idea because it takes
away the primary it may not I mean if
they still want a primary they can still
primary they still have the option
but it kind of solidifies you know
listen
here's what we can do
so Gavin Newsom
needs to go meet with Dianne Feinstein
they need to have this talk they need to
work this out Feinstein does need to be
a part of the the conversation my God
she has been in office she deserves to
be part of the the conversation she's
been there for so long she's an
institution
but she's also done her service and it's
time to pass that torch but that torch
has to be passed in a way that doesn't
screw over the Democratic Party in the
House of Representatives and right now
that is exactly what we're headed
towards like that's what's gonna happen
but we can avoid that if she resigns
and Gavin Newsom can appoint that
replacement
so Gavin Newsom could say listen all
right Katie Porter
you're the senator now
which would mean obviously Katie Porter
wouldn't lose her seat
we could probably avoid a messy primary
at that point
and go from there he could say Barbara
Lee you're the senator now
that may make Katie Porter say okay look
if she's got it now clearly she'll win
the primary I'm going to back out I'm
gonna keep going on my house seat
it may not work the way that I'm
thinking you know I I could be wrong
about this this is just my idea my
theory but I think it's the best and
smartest move
let Feinstein resign on her own terms
let her have a say in what happens to
the seat I know that's not how politics
is supposed to work the people get the
choice
but for the good of the Democratic Party
we can't lose those voices for the good
of the country we can't lose both those
voices in the house we simply cannot
and this may avoid that may not be the
prettiest scenario it may not be the
thing that everybody loves to do
but I think it's the smartest path
forward at this point
and finally today
that footage that Tucker Carlson got his
hands on 44 000 hours of footage from
January 6th security cameras all over
Congress given to him by Kevin McCarthy
a coalition of news organizations are
now suing the federal government to get
their hands on that very same footage
that has been handed over to Tucker
Carlson
those organizations include Advanced
Publications the Associated Press CNN
CBS the ew Scripps company Gannett the
New York Times Politico and propublica
and basically what they've done is
they've sued the federal government
well not necessarily sued the federal
government I that man may be the wrong
word they filed a motion in federal
court saying that we have jumped through
all the Hoops we have filled out all the
paperwork the Freedom of Information Act
requests asking the FBI the doj to turn
over this same footage which is
technically already publicly available
via Tucker Carlson so it's not like it's
hidden it's not like it's top secret or
classified
we want this information so the the news
organizations are asking the court to
compel the government to turn it over to
them
I hope this lawsuit works I think it
needs to work for the good of the
country because Tucker Carlson got that
footage and did exactly what everybody
predicted he was going to do
he showed weird camera angles that just
showed people walking down a hallway and
then he was like see they're not violent
it's just like tourists on a trip
they're learning it's a field trip
and of course he omitted all of the part
where they're breaking Windows climbing
up walls smashing vases stealing stuff
jumping over chairs with a bundle of zip
ties on their belt yeah all the really
important things Tucker Carlson said
yeah we don't need to talk about that
he's whitewashing the events of that day
to make Republicans look better
these news organizations want that same
footage so that they can show what
really happened
you can't just show a piece of the
puzzle and say oh yes clearly that is a
basket of puppies
you have to put the whole puzzle
together every single piece of it and
another thing
that I think Tucker Carlson didn't take
into consideration is that those people
that he's shown just walking around that
building being peaceful
their very presence in that building
is what's a crime because even if they
were just walking around
they were still trespassing on federal
property and interrupting an official
government proceeding so those videos
Tucker showed could actually lead to
more prosecutions and arrests in the
future
listen that's all the time we have for
today I've got an exceptionally fun
bonus show coming up thank you David
thank you team for letting me fill in uh
for these last two days I am fair and
cousins you can find me on YouTube at
youtube.com the ring of fire youtube.com
fair and balanced Twitter Facebook
Instagram Tick Tock at farrenbalanced
thank you so much stay tuned for the
bonus show
thank you